believe it or not The Lost Boys was
originally supposed to be a more
wholesome Peter Pan inspired vampire
movie but following the success of st.
Elmo's fire director Joel Schumacher
turned the project into a sexy gory and
politically subversive teenage classic
that changed the way vampires would be
portrayed in Hollywood for decades to
come
well it still holds up as one of the
better vampire films ever made there's
probably a lot you don't know about this
cult classic
so grab your leather jacket hold on to
the rails and check out the untold truth
of the Lost Boys Santa Carla you don't
have to be from California to know that
Santa Carla the town where the Lost Boys
takes place doesn't actually exist
however locals can easily recognize a
Lost Boys location as the south bay
beach town Santa Cruz thanks to shots of
its Giant Dipper roller coaster director
Joel Schumacher fell in love with the
locale as soon as he scouted it telling
the local news the movie didn't come
together until I saw Santa Cruz at the
time there was an enormous amount of
transient kids moving through Santa Cruz
this is exactly where I would come if I
was a teenage vampire after reversing a
couple of letters and nearby Santa Clara
he even had a locally inspired new name
for his movies dream spot the cast
enjoyed filming in the scenic beach town
- Corey Feldman recalled we had such a
great time there being kids and having
the opportunity to be at the boardwalk
every day getting to ride in the Giant
Dipper and being at the beach it was
such a fun experience however securing
Santa Cruz as a film's location wasn't
all smooth sailing
the town's authorities were weary of the
boardwalk being portrayed in a bad light
especially after 1983 violent sudden
impact took them by surprise
even worse Santa Carla's title as the
murder capital the world wasn't
fictional as Santa Cruz earned that
description after years of serial
killings but the authorities read The
Lost Boys script loved it and ended up
giving Schumacher the greenlight and the
rest is pop culture history Goonies gone
vampire The Lost Boys was initially
skewed towards a much younger audience
the film's original script written by
Jan Fisher and James Jeremias
was intended to be as the title suggests
a reimagining of Peter Pan with vampires
however as Schumacher told the Telegraph
he thought it read too much like The
Goonies go vampire especially with
Goonies director Richard Donner orig
at the helm and corey feldman joining
the cast when donger departed the
project a direct lethal weapon
Schumacher gained control and took the
lost boys from very wholesome to very
campy he explained the Frog brothers
were Boy Scouts I thought why can't they
all be teenagers why can't they be
dressed incredibly and why can't they
have stripped-down motorcycles that
looks skeletal Schumacher posed these
questions to Warner Brothers president
mark Kenton who ultimately gave him
permission to give the script a teenage
makeover Alex winter who played Marco
praised the changes saying I don't think
I really connected with it until I got
there and realized quite how deep joel
was going he really got it cinematically
and was taking it to this crazy place
Edgar Rambo thanks to his connection
with Goonies director Richard Donner
Corey Feldman received an invitation to
audition for the part of the Lost Boys
vampire slaying Edgar frog but when he
read through the script of Joel
Schumacher he got an interesting note he
was like that was great but could you
maybe butch it up a little bit
Feldman says he was instructed to hit
the video store and rent the movies of
Sylvester Stallone and Chuck Norris
telling him that is your character I
want you to meld all of these guys
together and make something out of it
Feldman's portrayal of Edgar frog
certainly breathed some comedic life
into the film which is often pretty dark
and serious of that Feldman said I think
the fun part about the character and the
comic value of it is that he doesn't
think it's funny and he's not in on the
joke so he's one of those people that
you just kind of have to laugh at
because you know they really take
themselves very seriously and they
believed every word of what they're
saying about themselves or whatever it
is they believe in challenging
conventions The Lost Boys may be campy
but it also challenged certain common
conventions about family life in America
the Atlantic argues that the movie
arrived at a time when many Americans
were fearful of a perceived
disintegration of the traditional
nuclear family structure The Lost Boys
challenged these notions by focusing on
two non-traditional families the
Emerson's and the vampire crew as the
good guys the Emerson's survive and
ultimately thrive despite the mother
being newly divorced broke and forced to
move into her father's house with her
two sons when we meet max the one father
type character who could offer a
traditional fix to the broken Emerson
family it turns out he's also a
monster meanwhile the film's other
family is a bunch of dudes living
sleeping partying and killing together
additionally the film is also commonly
analysed as challenging conservative
notions of sexuality all at a time when
the President of the United States was
accused of ignoring the country's
incredibly serious AIDS crisis today
much of the Lost Boys is commonly viewed
as homoerotic Santa Carla itself
represents a place where people on the
outskirts of society such as homosexuals
and vampires can live openly David and
his crew of vampires dress in leather
outfits not unlike those worn by members
of the early 80s underground gay club
scene and new vampires must drink
David's blood in an initiation ceremony
Sam's bedroom is decorated with a poster
of Rob Lowe's apse Michael fearing his
actions with David have led him down a
deviant path rushes off to have sex with
Starr whom none of the other vampires
seem particularly interested in
Schumacher himself even endorses these
analyses telling GamesRadar that the
Lost Boys is in a way about the fear we
have of the other those who live outside
of the mainstream all about Michael
anyone who has ever even passively
watched The Lost Boys has the name
Michael permanently engraved in their
memories of the movie that's because the
protagonists name is uttered more than
any other word in the entire film just
how many times do we hear his name well
over a hundred Michael Michael Michael
Michael Michael
considering the film's runtime is only
97 minutes that means viewers got at
least one Michael mentioned a minute
which is a lot of name love for one half
vampire to receive a tale of two Coreys
child stars Corey Haim and Corey Feldman
were a late 80s dynamic duo appearing
together in pics like license to drive
dream a little dream and national
lampoon's last resort but it was a lost
boys that first paired the young actors
who later be referred to as the two
Coreys we just clicked on a chemistry
for ourselves and people I guess getting
wind of it like wow these two have
something off camera but on camera
unfortunately a series of ill-advised
personal and professional decisions
derailed both Corey's careers and their
brief peak as teenage heart throbs
belied a slew of direct-to-video
releases sadly even their on-screen
reunion on the short-lived reality show
the two Coreys couldn't save
Corey Haim who passed away in 2010 at
the age of 38 Ben Stiller lost boy
keeper Sutherlands crew of
leather-wearing teenage vampires of rock
and roll haircuts almost included
another up-and-comer we all know now Ben
Stiller has claimed that he was almost
cast as one of the Lost Boys telling a
Hollywood crowd in 2010 last time I saw
a room full of so many talented faces
was when I auditioned for the Lost Boys
it was between me and Kieffer and the
two Coreys he might have been joking but
the actor would have been 21 at the time
of the production which makes him the
right age for one of the roles it's also
fairly easy to imagine the dark haired
Stiller wearing leather and riding a
motorcycle alongside Sutherland and crew
considering all the models that did make
it into the cast it's also easy to
picture Zoolander's patented blue steel
pose stacking up against Brooke
McCarter's tough guy smart quite nicely
stolen fiance while filming the Lost
Boys Jason Patric and Kiefer Sutherland
became close friends four years later
however Patrick was on an airplane to
Ireland with Sutherlands ex-fiance Julia
Roberts leading to some juicy tabloid
drama in 2016 Sutherland reflected on
the headline-making breakup from years
earlier we were young and we were both
very much in love and we had decided
that we wanted to get married she was
arguably the most famous woman in the
world this wedding that was supposed to
be something between the two of us
became something so big I think she had
the courage you know it wasn't what she
wanted to do in the end not long after
her split with Sutherland however
Roberts started dating Patrick for his
part Patrick has since downplayed the
whole love triangle ordeal telling
vulture everything that happened was all
fake and booked and let them give you
quotes about whatever they want
obviously people are gonna ask they had
a relationship that ended and I was with
her for a little while and it ended
they've both been subsequently married
several times and I think they're fine
but we never had any issue even back
then indeed to this day Patrick claims
he has maintained his friendship with
Sutherland despite their brief romantic
rivalry it's just nice at all those
years later I'm still very good friends
of Jami Gertz very good friends at
Kiefer
it was a special time buffy the vampire
stealer as one of the first teenage
vampire films to feature some serious
sex appeal The Lost Boys inspired a
whole new sub-genre of vampire stories
including Buffy the Vampire Slayer Buffy
creator Joss Whedon has gone on record
to explain some of the ways his movie
and resulting TV series took inspiration
from the film as Whedon told salon back
in 2003 the idea of vampires looking
like monsters and then looking like
people that was in lost boys and that
was very useful for us you could have
somebody for you or someone like angels
seem like he's not a vampire and then he
is won the series second season
introduced a character named spike a
platinum blond vampire played by James
Marsters Whedon credited the Lost Boys
for the inspiration for the character
saying there's a little Billy Idol a
little Kiefer Sutherland in The Lost
Boys and every guy in a black coat skip
the sequels although The Lost Boys lives
on as a piece of cultural iconography
it's sequels definitely failed to earn
the same kind of hype why well the first
sequel took 20 years to happen and even
then it was still a straight-to-dvd sort
of deal titled Lost Boys the tribe the
movie did bring back Corey Feldman as
the only original cast member who made
it into the final cut and while it
features plenty of vampires and topless
women it has almost nothing to do with
the original film leading critics to
unanimously label it as little more than
a cheap cash grab it did manage to make
back its production costs upon release
however so Warner Brothers gave the
go-ahead to another titled Lost Boys the
thirst featuring the reunion of Feldman
and Jamison neulander as the Frog
brothers however it was slaughtered by
critics and sold half as many DVDs as
the first sequel so consider this one a
lost boy in its own right thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]